on the 8th of August 2008 the same day
that the 2008 Beijing Olympic Games
kicked off the Russian army launched its
full-scale invasion of Georgia
the most important event of the decade
for China the Olympic games that were to
Crown the process of the full
incorporation of the communist country
into the International Community was to
be marred by Vladimir Putin and his
war-mongering aspirations at that time
Xi Jinping was not yet at the helm of
China instead it was his predecessor
hujin Tao who reacted discreetly but was
deeply irritated with Moscow because of
the date chosen for the Invasion the
same day that the Olympic flame would
light up China for the first time
really
it seems visual part of the community
that although much has happened since
then some habits never change as if it
were a kind of deja vu Putin made the
decision to invade Ukraine just at the
time when China was hosting another
Olympic Games The Beijing 2022 Winter
Games in fact it is believed that Xi
Jinping asked the Russian leader to
postpone his invasion until after the
closing of the games and whether or not
this is true the point is that only four
days after the closing of these games
Hutton's hordes were launched on Ukraine
since then the attitude of the People's
Republic of China had been tremendously
ambiguous and erratic but one thing has
become very clear Xi Jinping is moving
further and further away from his
predecessors
foreign
all this time throughout a year of war
and despite the terrible crimes
committed by the Russian army the
Chinese dictator has remained silent and
on the sidelines at least until now this
image will surely take a long time to be
forgotten
[Music]
yes that's right the image that some
doubted would happen and that others
announced as inevitable finally came to
pass the dictators of China and Russia
Xi Jinping and Vladimir Putin together
at a bilateral Summit in Moscow just one
year after the start of the war it was
not the first time they have met since
the beginning of the invasion but it was
the first time they met at the highest
level and within the framework of a
bilateral Summit perhaps for this reason
many have interpreted G's visit to
Moscow as an endorsement of Putin a way
to legitimize the Russian leader on the
international scene and perhaps also to
whitewash his operations even more so
when the visit took place only a few
days after news stories like this one
broke ICC judges issue arrest warrant
for Vladimir Putin over alleged war
crimes however this is only the footnote
the truth is that she visit to Russia is
about more than handshakes or forced
Smiles it was above all beijing's latest
attempt to become the capital most
antagonistic to Washington once and for
all the clear alternative to Western
leadership now does this mean that China
will ultimately side with Russia is
Beijing really as neutral as they claim
to be what on Earth are the true Chinese
intentions with this apparent reproach
mall with Putin who has the upper hand
in this whole story well visual Baltic
viewers in this video we're going to
answer all of these questions so stay
tuned
[Music]
the multipolar order
take a look at this striking moment here
you see Wang Yi head of the Chinese
Communist party's Central commission for
foreign affairs XI jinping's top foreign
policy advisor together with
representatives of Saudi Arabia and Iran
two countries that in theory hate each
other have now decided to re-establish
diplomatic relations and they have done
so thanks to China's mediation it is not
very common to see the Chinese as
mediators in international problems but
it seems that now this is precisely the
new path that the Chinese regime wants
to follow and the conflict between
Russia and Ukraine seems to be their
next Target
at the end of February 2023 coinciding
with the first anniversary of the war
China presented a 12-point plan too in
theory provide a political solution to
the conflict in reality this was
something of a take it or leave it plan
they didn't even consult Ukraine's
opinion on the 12 points presented nor
are they very concise in fact most of
the points include extremely General
things like respecting the sovereignty
of all countries ceasing hostilities and
reducing strategic risks the important
thing is that with this document China
already had its peace plan
theoretically now the Chinese are going
to start working to see how these points
can be realized and that is surely what
explains news items like this one in the
Chinese media European leaders trips to
China highlight beijing's role as a
peace promoters
but of course the doubt the big question
mark in this whole story is can we
really consider China as a neutral
player between Russia and Ukraine
capable of acting as a mediating country
in this conflict
well what can I say words like these
ones probably don't help
and I don't know about you but for a G
to tell Putin that they are driving
changes together doesn't seem like the
best cover letter for becoming a
mediator however just a moment because
to stop at these images would be a
terrible simple and unfortunate analysis
of this whole situation Beijing talks
about its peace plan but what if China
really doesn't care if the war ends soon
that's right you heard me that is the
actual question here
let me explain initially this war was a
nuisance for China suddenly everyone
began to worry about National Security
Western support of Ukraine overcame
barriers that could be considered a
precedent for other situations like
Taiwan the United States greatly
improved its International standing and
had the luxury of restricting the sale
of advanced technology to China itself
and to top it all off the global
economic slowdown contributed to China's
economic growth in 2022 falling to
almost half of the government's Target
however where there is a will there is a
way take note because right now we will
identify at least three main reasons why
things may not be seen by the Chinese
regime the same way that we see them the
first of these has to do with do the
extraordinary economic benefits China is
getting from Western sanctions on Russia
do you want a concrete example of all
this of course you do so take a look at
this graph
of course energy is the key driver of
China's Imports
[Music]
the war sanctions and European
disengagement from Russia have allowed
China to buy record amounts of gas and
oil at deep discounts just when its
economy is not at its best Russia needs
to sell as much as it can even if that
means selling much more cheaply and so
in the months of January and February of
2023 with an increase of almost 24 year
on year Russia unseated Saudi Arabia as
China's largest oil supplier
of course Russia cannot flood China with
oil and gas basically because a it lacks
the infrastructure and B unlike the
Germans the Chinese have always been
very wary of their energy security at
the beginning of 2023 Russia's share of
Chinese purchases was already above 20
so the margin seems small however the
idea now is to replace purchases using
ships with gas sent via pipelines we are
talking for instance about trying to
speed up the deadlines for the
construction of power of Siberia 2 a new
gas pipeline that could transport
through more than 2 600km kilometers up
to 50 billion cubic meters of gas which
would double the current Russian gas
export capacity to China
[Music]
of course there is one problem Chinese
estimates are to import 38 billion cubic
meters of gas by 2025 while the Russians
aspire to be able to sell them 98 BCM by
2030. and with oil it is a very similar
story let's just say there is a massive
divide between what China wants to buy
and what Russia wants to sell so for the
Chinese to agree to further increase
their energy exposure to Russia the
Kremlin will have to commit to much
lower prices give guarantees and jump
through the Hoops of whatever King ji
says because don't forget one thing this
is not a relationship between equals the
special relationship between Russia and
China may end up making the former a
kind of vassal state of the latter and
this is in fact the Second Great
advantage that the war could have for
China a much greater political influence
a new degree of influence that they have
themselves have dubbed the multi-polar
order
the idea of the multi-polar order is to
bring together the power spheres of
Russia and China the russophile and
xenophile world to create a new Global
power access to serve as a counterweight
to the U.S in all Fields the small
detail is that now with the enormous
weakening that Russia is suffering China
could take advantage of that situation
to impose its geopolitical economic and
Military interests over any Russian
demands
any examples of where this could go well
one of the possible scenarios in which
China could use Russia to consolidate
its power would be in Africa but it is
not only about the geostratic field when
we talk about Chinese influence there is
also the economic field take a look at
this Putin told she rushes ready to
switch to UAMS in foreign trade
basically what this change would imply
is that Russia would stop trading in
dollars with countries in Asia Latin
America and Africa switching to the
Renminbi which is the name of China's
currency commonly known as the UN
in fact in 2022 the un's share of
Russians export payments increased from
0.5 to 16 and for example in February
2023 the UN overtook the dollar for the
first time in history as the most traded
currency on the Moscow stock exchange
with almost 40 percent of transactions
it is what many have already called the
petrol un of course its consequences
have been greatly exaggerated the UN is
not capable of replacing the dollar why
basically because it lacks legal
certainty and because China maintains
strict Capital controls but even so this
change could boost China's influence in
Russia and in general throughout the
entire Central Asian region finally
there is the military issue
[Music]
Russia is suffering an enormous amount
of military attrition which along with
the sanctions as having two very clear
consequences on the one hand Russia's
military capability has been sapped
virtually leaving China as the sole
major military power in Central Asia on
the other hand when the war is over and
Russia needs to acquire newer military
equipment to replace its losses if the
sanctions are not lifted they are likely
to turn to the chain Chinese military
industry for hardware and components and
it's not just Russia a good many of
Russia's customers could gradually shift
to Chinese industry
so there you have it these would be the
three ways in which China could aspire
to benefit from all this mess Three core
ideas with which Xi Jinping seems to
want to make up for the great blow that
the war has caused them and right here
is where we come to a big dilemma check
this out
[Music]
the great dilemma
[Applause]
[Music]
what we have told you in this video if
you had to answer the question we asked
you at the beginning about whether or
not China is really neutral in regards
to Russia what answer would you give
China does not have a neutral position
basically because Xi Jinping has found a
path in the war to push his particular
agenda of confrontation with the West
also don't forget that the Chinese
economy is starting to experience a lot
of problems so there is nothing better
than having a scapegoat on hand you know
how it goes no we're not to blame for
the problems it's because of the war
however this is not the whole story
right here we have arrived at the great
dilemma facing the Chinese government on
the one hand as we have seen the war may
have benefits for XI jinping's new
agenda but on the other hand it also
involves many problems that media
Outlets usually Overlook
for example the war is causing its
asia-pacific neighbors to increase their
military spending and move even closer
to the United States this may
structurally weaken China's Ambitions to
become the dominant power in the Asia
Pacific region at the same time it is
also contributing to the further
deterioration of China's already Eddie
strained economic trade and political
relations with the West which is exactly
what China does not need right now let's
just say that the war has made many
governments perceive dictatorships like
Putin's and XI jinping's as finally
untrustworthy
au's Wonderland calls for tougher policy
on China ahead of Beijing visit
China has now turned the page on the
area of Reform and opening and is moving
into a new era of security and control
our relationship is unbalanced and
increasingly affected by distortions
created by China's State capitalist
system so we need to rebalance this
relationship this is why we have put
forward the critical raw materials Act
to help diversify and secure answers
as part of this we will focus on free
trade agreements where we do not yet
have them such as with New Zealand
Australia India partners
to make matters worse this war is also
slowing global economic growth a growth
that China needs more than ever if it is
to overcome all the problems it faces we
are talking about things like the
bursting of the real estate bubble the
technology crisis banking problems hyper
indebtedness of local governments and so
on and so forth and of course if they
fail to overcome all these imbalances
the New multi-polar World Order of which
they dream so much could be a very
short-lived one
[Music]
it seems that Xi Jinping has
dramatically turned the rudder with
respect to his predecessors and the
results have not been particularly good
now there seems to be their latest
gamble to try and cash in on the war
Russia has provoked in Ukraine of course
it is not clear that China can really
derive any benefit from this game what
is clear is that it is neither a neutral
country nor a reliable regime but for
now the questions are over to you do you
think China will manage to benefit from
the current situation will Russia end up
becoming a kind of vassal state of
Beijing what future do you predict for
the alliance between China and Russia
will they really be able to promote a
new world order leave us your answers
and comments below and if you found this
video interesting don't forget to like
And subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik and check out our patreon
to keep up to date with all our content
all the best and I'll see you next time
[Music]